hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen now every year I have
people ask me okay Abby what is next for
your business honestly while I love the
rhythm that I've got going on with my
blog and my youtube channel and my book
I am NOT one to Coast and one of the big
things that have been on my bucket list
forever is to create my own merch line
honestly I have attempted it many times
before doing months and months of
research on supplier quality and
inventory and crunching the numbers
ultimately to make sure that the
investment was worth the risk and I just
never found a product that I felt
confident in that is until I discovered
this amazing company called influence
for impact
well actually I owe it to Stephanie
better more for the introduction because
I loved her merch line so much that I
received to her about who she was
working with and the rest as they say
was history
but like recent history because we
busted our asses to get this line I
dated and design and produced for you
ASAP now let me tell you about why I
love these shirts so much so all of the
products from the manufacturer I'm
working with are made out of up cycled
or organic materials made from
sustainable materials and recycled
plastics and a portion of all proceeds
raised from any sales in my shop will go
towards supporting sick kids as a mom
there is nothing that scares me more
than the thought of my son getting hurt
or sick honestly I know that there's
going to be a lot of scraped knees and
probably a lot of broken bones just
judging by the way he whips around the
house on his scooter every day but I am
just so grateful and at ease knowing
that when that day comes or god forbid
something more serious happens to come
our way that sick kids is going to be
there donations to sick kids will help
them construct a better campus for young
patients and their family
continue with their breakthrough
research and children's health and
disease and create initiatives that span
across the world at least 10% of all
proceeds raised in my shop will
automatically he donate to sick kids so
every single sale really counts now let
me tell you about the goods first is my
snack shirt and sweatshirt so the snack
sure was one of my favorites because
obviously you guys know I love to snack
but also I like to like you snack as a
descriptor for people like you're such a
little snack eat your baby such a cute
snack can't forget one of my favorite
lines from the best movie of all time
Billy Madison I mean come on folks it's
a great work if you're feeling like a
snack why not look like a snack next is
my balanced shirt okay so the balanced
shirt I felt really embodied my channel
and the fact that when I talk about food
and our relationship to food in our body
I'm always striving for balance and
really not just with food but in so many
other areas of our life as well it
really is my ultimate goal so I really
want to embody that in my clothing line
so I definitely think I'm gonna be
wearing this shirt when I'm having a bit
of a stressful anxious day and I need to
ground myself and recenter okay the
saucy shirt I just thought was super fun
because I don't know it's one of my
favorite descriptors as like a character
trait even though when I was little and
my mom would say Abbi
don't be saucy it would be you know in
response to a day where I was maybe not
being super agreeable but as an adult
I've decided to like embrace that
characteristic because who wants to be
incessantly agreeable that is so boring
and so not fun so I'm rockin the saucy
these days okay so folks the caffeinated
and motivated shirt is pretty much my
daily mood I'm going to live in this all
day every day but basically it's a
really fun one for just hanging out with
friends we're going out for coffee you
can dress it up and keep it super casual
and I think it's just like a really fun
mantra to live by okay the let's brunch
shirt I mean you know where you're gonna
wear this you're gonna wear to brunch of
course
but I think everybody loves brunch I'm
from Toronto and Torontonians literally
live for brunch we will line up all day
every single weekend to get into the hot
spots for brunch but I think brunch is
just really fun because it's like when
you're young and you're single it's a
really great excuse to day drink and
when you're a parent it's pretty much
the only way that you're getting out of
the house on the weekend
so I'm really looking forward to rocking
this one all weekend long all of the
sweatshirts in the line are made out of
100% organic cotton fleece and the
t-shirts are a hemp and organic cotton
blend both are crazy comfortable for
casual wear but also something that you
can actually dress up if you want to
wear it with a nice pair of heels sizing
wise I'm wearing an extra small for a
really fitted look but I also have a few
shirts and small for days that I want
something a little bit more casual and
relaxed but for your reference
I am five-seven and approximately 125
pounds all the products range from extra
small to 3x and they're unisex so guys
you can totally rock this to also
giveaway alert if you want to be one of
the first people to get your hands on
this line I'm going to be doing a
giveaway here and over on my Instagram
at Abby's kitchen and you can enter on
both of these platforms so if you want
to enter first you need to like and
comment on this video you also are gonna
want to like and comment on my Instagram
video for this launch follow at Abby's
kitchen on Instagram if you are not
already subscribe to my YouTube channel
if you're not already like come on folks
and then tag a friend in the comment
section on my Instagram who you think
would also love this line each comment
equals one entry so you can take as many
friends as you want well folks I hope
that you love these products and you'll
join me in helping to support sick kids
I also want you to know that this is
just the start of my merch line so
there's a lot more fun to come now
friends what I want to know from you is
which shirt are you going to grab first
leave me a comment below with your
thoughts on the line and of course be
sure to share this with someone who
would love these shirts subscribe to the
channel if you're not already also once
you get your order in the mail please
try it on snap a pic and
DME I cannot wait to see you guys rock
in this line and don't forget to enter
the giveaway to win some of these shirts
all the details to enter the giveaway
are in the description below so
definitely check that out and I hope to
see you guys next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
[Music]